[Music]
welcome everybody to hy be 102
incrementally adopting sto my name is
Sunday Parikh unfortunately my
co-presenter tahira couldn't be here
today he ended up not getting his
passport with his visa back in time to
make it over here from Singapore so he
couldn't make it but he was he was very
upset about it kid he had a lot of good
stuff to share so we're gonna find
another way for him to get some of the
slides that he was going to present back
out to y'all at another time so today
we're gonna cover the what the why and
the how of sto dude scheduling I think
this session would have been better
served on earlier on Tuesday before a
lot of the other service mesh and SEO
sessions that kicked off but I don't
make the rules on that so we'll have to
go talk to people in marketing about
that later on so this is coming sort of
in the middle of some of the 200-level
stuff and some of the 300 level things
are still happening tomorrow as well
but just for for my own actually
education I'd love to know how many of
you by show of hands have used SEO or
played with this deal at all
what about sto and production who's got
a co in production okay awesome
very cool by the way I hope you all saw
who raised their hand so you can go talk
to them if you've got questions after
the talk is over all right so just a
quick little bit about me I'm a
developer advocate or a cognitive
advocate the title changes all the time
for Google cloud and before Google I
worked at mommy to be an apple and a
bunch of other random startups you can
find me on Twitter
Eric github with the same username it's
people always ask it's circus monkey -
the vowels and the content that I'm
going to talk about today is up and a
repo there as well and I'll have the
link at the end so you guys can pull
that down I'm gonna do a little bit of
slides and there's a little bit of demo
at the end but all the material is
actually a fully baked you know set of
tutorials you can walk through alright
so let's start with why sto right we've
just finished kind of getting into
kubernetes and be comfortable there
and now we're gonna add another layer of
abstraction on top of it
why do we want to do this right why is
Sto so critically useful and important
to deployments right we have containers
containers are great we love containers
right
it lets us be really portable and get
out of this hole like it worked on my
machine but not over there and in
production so we can get this sort of
unified environment get this great
packaging containers awesome kubernetes
also great all right it does a lot of
great things for us it orchestrates
those containers really well let's uh
schedule them out and bin pack him very
tightly into a cluster really powerful
but micro-services deployments are hard
by their by their just very nature right
you have a bunch of services strewn
across a cluster teams are iterating at
different paces
you've got dependencies you don't even
know about right again spread out across
this whole thing applying policy
applying control is challenging in that
environment right SEO helps us get from
that's sort of kind of mess on the left
to something it's more organized and
functional on the right if you think
about some of the again that higher
level of abstraction right so we've
moved on from just containers and pods
and and scheduling them and deploying
them into a cluster but again if you
think about that next level up what
makes those micro services deployments
hard right so a good example is canary
releases are doing blue green or you
know traffic splitting if you want to do
that in kubernetes today you actually
have to run the correct ratio of pods so
if you want to do something like a 90/10
split to test out you know v1 versus V -
you'd actually have to run you know nine
pods of v1 and one pot of v2 to make
sure you've got that 90/10 split that's
kind of a pain that requires a little
too much
hand-holding to really work well you
don't know who you're talking to you
write your services could have a person
in the middle or a service in the middle
there or you could be opening yourself
up to some kind of attacker injection
right you want to make sure that
services are know who they're
communicating with back and forth you
want to be able to quickly dig into high
latency drivers again if you think of a
micro services deployment you may have a
Weber
Quest's that comes in the front end but
it may travel around to a number of
other services well how do you know if
it's slow right the end user might feel
like well this is taking 500
milliseconds or over a thousand
milliseconds but it might not be the
front end it might be one of the various
backends that that front end is talking
to and there's a whole host of other
things right like digging into l.7
attributes like request headers we can't
do that right out of the box of
kubernetes you can't really control who
accesses services and you can't track
requests from start to finish so you
don't have a level of visibility to
match again the complexity of the
deployment you're doing so that's a
little bit of why we think sto is really
powerful because it gives you access to
all these so again we've talked about
service mesh many of you obviously have
played with this yes you have some some
understanding here but I like to start
with this idea of what is SEO right sto
if you think of it and you know if if
you boil it down to its kind of simplest
concept SCO is about automation right it
goes beyond I think with just a sort of
a service mesh I don't think that really
encapsulates it SEO gives you this power
to apply policy and control to your
entire deployment whether it's five
services or five hundred services you
can take a single rule and say I want to
turn on MPLS and make every service
mutually authenticate to each other with
one rule and that goes cluster wide
writer namespace wide depending how you
roll it out so the three things that sto
kind of gives you around in the in those
areas of automation are one very uniform
observability right metrics logging
tracing right out-of-the-box operational
agility which is a fancy way of saying I
think a lot of traffic and networking
control and then a very deterministic
policy driven security model so if
you're digging a little bit further with
telemetry you can examine all of that
traffic in and out of those services and
in and out of your cluster as well with
very little to no instrumentation in
many cases right that's incredibly
powerful you can take the responsibility
of adding in things like latency and
tracing outside of the hands of
developers and say you don't have to
worry about instrumenting this
as a starting point we'll learn a lot
just by putting this thing and running
it with SEO same thing is true of
traffic you can take the network and
control outside of the application make
that a loosely coupled structure so
applications can be deployed however
they need to be your services can be
deployed in whatever we make sense but
then the cluster operator can decide how
traffic's blink should happen how
rollout should happen and then finally
security obviously right being able to
secure access and communication between
services or add authentication policies
to individual services or all of them
depending how you want to roll it out so
at a glance it's do is again it does add
complexity right where we're sort of
solving complexity by adding some other
complexity so that's a little bit of a
trade-off in terms of how much it has to
happen but if you think about it what
you're effectively trying to do is one
narrow the problem space a little bit
you're trying to tell your application
teams take the complexity away from them
you're saying don't worry about
networking control don't worry about
some of the telemetry aspects don't
worry about security we'll take the
complexity away from them and we'll put
it on this on the cluster operator but
then we'll give them again that
automation to apply those things in a
much more granular way and be able to
again incrementally roll it out so if
you start with the most basic component
that's the sto sidecar proxy and you'll
see that little little hexagons over
there that's actually the Envoy logo so
the sto sidecar is powered by envoy
right it's effectively the Envoy proxy
Envoy is a fantastic project fantastic
piece of code it's very high performant
and because it lives in your pod right
alongside your application container or
services container they share the same
Network space which means it can
actually capture and filter through all
the traffic going in and out so it adds
a thin little layer of control over the
traffic going in and out of your
containers the next part is I guess we
call it sort of the data plane right
which things are sort of generating and
pushing data out or implementing rules
again that's the Envoy proxy piece
itself but when you kind of slice across
your cluster we consider those proxies
as that
go data plane in the cluster and this is
something you can deploy today you can
take the envoy open-source proxy and
deploy it as part of your containers or
part of your pods today what's missing
is a central control plane to deliver
rules and configuration to those proxies
and that's really what Sto provides it
kind of packages this whole thing up and
gives you a unified control plane with a
series of components to push rules and
configuration information out and so
inside that control plane there's
there's three main components right
there's actually a fourth one I didn't
mention here galley which is responsible
for handling some of the configuration
components but the three main ones that
we tend to deal with on a regular basis
are pilot mixer and Citadel so pilots
responsibility is taking in the rules
that you give it and making sure they
get back out to all those call those
proxies so at any point in the lifetime
of your cluster your deployment you can
see all of your pods and the rules that
pilot have sent out and figure out which
ones have synced and which ones have it
which ones have gotten the latest
version of the rules which ones have it
so you have that control there mixers
job is is to take metrics and telemetry
data that come out of those proxies and
then send them downstream to the
telemetry backend of your choice whether
it's prometheus Griffon a-- stackdriver
you name it and the last one Citadel is
responsible for managing certificates so
its job is to make sure everybody's got
the right certificates and keys and
authentication information and it does
the magic of rotating those things
around all on its own so that's a little
bit of the components of istria but what
is this you're really do for you right
let's if we get into some of that detail
so if we start with observability or
observing as I mentioned you get
automatic tracing logging and monitoring
by default so as long as you send your
logs out to localhost as long as you
publish your metrics on you know a known
good endpoints and you whether you do or
you don't actually add any tracing
information it can actually still
develop deliver some tracing information
out from your applications so those
proxies they send that tracing in that
telemetry data to mixer
and mixer has a well-formed adapter API
that lets it send all that data to
particular backends and you could again
split these out so you may say well if
I'm running in in gke inside of Google
Cloud maybe I want to use stack driver
logging extract driver trace but you
really love for meatiest and gore fauna
by all means you can put those two
together so you could have that mix of
different backends and components
depending on the piece you want you
could even have it so you'd push metrics
to Prometheus and distract driver if you
wanted to there's no real limit to how
you can configure this for connecting
services right that kind of operational
agility component was really where the
networking piece comes in there's a few
objects that are really dedicated
specifically to networking inside of sto
and those are virtual services
destination rules gateways and service
entries and so those in some combination
of one or more of those daily you do
things like traffic splitting traffic
steering right from one version to
another fault injection circuit braking
and egress control which is really
powerful right if you have a lot of
services that call external API s this
is a really powerful way to put some
control over that but more importantly
as a security mechanism or to form a
better security posture let's say you
have a bad docker image that you pulled
and deployed maybe a malformed tag or
maybe something got injected into that
container well if you lock down egress
control that means nobody can make
outbound recall about an API calls are
up on calls unless you've specifically
allowed that service so now you're
getting just sort of this free kind of
perimeter around your deployment just by
having that proxy and having this
infrastructure in place if we dig in a
little bit to some of the traffic
splitting and traffic steering the way
the Envoy proxy works is you sent rules
up to pilot in that configuration pilot
sends those rules to in those individual
proxies so now those proxies themselves
know how to route traffic around from
one to the other so in the top example
we've got service a and service B
service B has a has you know different
versions that it might have if you just
rely on kubernetes
routing you get round-robin routing
right so you're basically get an
equivalent amount of requests spread
across here so in the example and the
right side in the upper right there
example you might see like 25% going to
each pod with sto we can actually
control this to say well we want ninety
five and five we want to have a canary
version that we roll out very slowly on
the bottom example that's really where
we get into things like traffic steering
again because of the way envoy works it
can actually inspect the headers coming
in to your applications so that means we
can actually say based on maybe a header
value I might want to direct traffic to
a particular version or a particular pod
so for example you could say hey for
logged in users running on iOS with
WebKit version XYZ direct them to this
canary roll out test or this other
version of that service so you have that
level of control that you didn't have
just again with with sort of vanilla
kubernetes and last I mentioned earlier
you can also inject things along the way
and these are really not necessarily
things you're gonna use in a production
environment but for more of like a
testing and resiliency perspective you
may want to inject things like delay
sort of retries or even other connection
rules circuit breaking is a good example
you can inject a circuit breaker inside
of this path between services and
control you know whether you want
cascade failures to happen or if your
quest starts to fail just cut off access
immediately so you're not seeing your
end users aren't seeing sort of high
latency waiting for errors to timeout
all the way through and as with a lot of
the way sto works those rules can match
very particular conditions and be
directed at a percentage of requests not
all requests are just some so you have
again a very granular control that you
can really implement across your
platform on the security front four main
components that really stand out right
encrypting traffic between services
authenticating services or service
authentication services service I should
say I'm auditing control and access
control policies right again very
powerful stuff
think of it this way I can implement
again mutual TLS is a good example and
actually one that a customer came to us
they were told by one of their
downstream customers that they needed to
encrypt traffic between all services and
if Co was the fastest way for them to
get there because they redeployed their
pods with the sidecar proxy and then
flipped a bit with one rule to turn on
mutual authentication across everything
there and that's really powerful the
security model it this diagram is a
little bit hard to read in a few spots
the point is it's kind of rolling
together all of the security parts of
the infrastructure that you can kind of
inject along the way so requests are
coming in on the far left and sort of
traversing through to the far right on
the egress side and you can see where
citadel's issuing certificates where
things like service authentication maybe
withdraw tokens or MPLS between services
is happening so you have again this this
level of control that's not really
possible without another higher-level
tool so that's a little bit of the
background of you know the why and sort
of the what of isseo but how do you put
if co2 work for yourself right and this
is where i'm gonna get to this idea of
incrementally rolling it out because
like with any new technology could
really want to start and go from zero to
a hundred percent on day one you want to
find the features that make the most
sense and then start rolling those out
bit by bit so the easiest way to get
started with this do is actually we
build something inside of google
kubernetes engine a little add-on that
lets you deploy SEO by default or along
with your cluster deployment so using
either G cloud or there the cloud
console you can actually spin up a
kubernetes cluster and there's a little
section called add ons and just check
the box for SEO and then pick a security
approach whether you want permissive or
strict and for the purposes of this
example I used empty less permissive
just to make things a little bit easier
but that's something I started with here
so this is an easy way to get it but
frankly installing the OSS versions not
that terribly challenging either right
grab the latest release apply it via the
helm chart and you're off and running
and with the helm chart you get the
level of customizability you might want
so for example maybe you decide today I
only really care about telemetry only
get two components that worried about
telemetry don't worry about having the
traffic components or the security
components you can always upgrade to
that later on using helm so helm gives
you that power and flexibility oh and
there's also a Quick Start inside the
sto repo as well that just deploys
everything so you have a couple of
different options for how to get the
software running inside of your cluster
once you do this and once this cluster
comes up you end up with a bunch of pods
running inside the Sto system namespace
and again it's all those things we saw
earlier pilot Citadel galley among other
things like depending on which version
you installed OSS or whether using the
one we package here for you
if you use this version we install all
the stack driver adapters for you by
default if you use SS it comes with
Prometheus and Griffin out of the box so
you have a couple different options
there but once you've got this up and
running once the system is ready you can
actually start to include the sidecar
proxy inside of your pods and there's
two ways to do it the bottom way is the
way we see a lot of folks do it which is
basically taking a namespace and saying
anything that gets deployed to that
namespace by default just Auto inject a
sidecar proxy or you have the other
approach of saying well I'm gonna do it
on a per sort of llamo basis every time
I push a new service I'm gonna filter my
Yambol through this sto control binary
that adds in the appropriate piece to
your pod spec so it includes the sidecar
proxy there's a couple different ways to
kind of get started there but if you're
rolling it out what I would say is don't
start with Auto injection right you
don't want the pot outright yet again it
really comes down through the features
that you're most interested in the other
thing I would also say and I mentioned
this a bit earlier is start with
permissive MPLS you can always turn it
on later but when you first turn it on
if you go with strict it might start to
break things so you might want to roll
it out again in a case by case or
service by service basis so that's just
a little bit of getting started let's go
through a couple of or a few example
kind of incremental roll outs right and
again think of this state of the cluster
as we've got a stew up and running we're
not Auto injecting the sidecar proxy yet
so for traffic management let's say
you've got a simple deployment here and
I wrote a little sample app called
weather info because I was getting
really tired of the built in book info I
just decide to make another one and it's
got a front-end in two different
backends right this just pulls the
weather from an external API v1 pulls it
from a single city and v2 pulls it for
four cities and just displays it out so
nothing fancy but let's say we want to
roll this out in a way again using sto
incrementally but we still want to take
advantage of some of the traffic
features that are available so how do we
do that right quick recap on traffic
splitting just to remember just to
remind you all right we will have this
approach we want to try to get this 95/5
now the difference here is that all of
these examples they've got the sidecar
proxy in them
so the question is and this is the
question I asked myself about six months
ago how can I do this kind of traffic
splitting without having to roll the
sidecar proxy out it turns out there's a
little bit of a cheat and a way to do it
it's not necessarily the way I would
recommend for everything especially for
full-blown but kind of large-scale
production employments but as you're
testing things out and getting
acquainted with the rules and
infrastructure it's a way to kind of
play with the networking api's before
again you go wide with it so what we're
trying to try to do here our goal is to
get to ninety ten and remember without
SDO right without anything by default
crew grades will just do round-robin
fifty-fifty across both of these so
that's where we're starting from we're
starting from 50/50 now this little
little box there is sto right and I've
got a little ingress gateway that's got
that's allowing inbound traffic at the
top so for us to get to this there's a
few components we have to deploy to make
it work so using a virtual service and a
destination rule we can actually direct
traffic from weather front end to
weather back end v1 at 90% and v2 at 10%
by directing traffic through the ingress
gateway so again rolling it out a little
bit slowly but getting a chance to test
this out and in a kind of a measured
approach so the traffic policy we want
to do for for this is the first thing we
do is create a destination rule and as
you can imagine by the name a
destination rule kind of tells inbound
traffic
so it's saying I want to direct traffic
to these possible subsets so in this
example all the destination rules really
saying is create some subsets of my
service in this case single and multiple
is what I called him right so we've got
a subset for single and a subset for
multiple I just want to have those on
record as being things I can direct
traffic to later on and then we create
the gateway component we connect a
gateway to the rest of the of the
infrastructure so what we're saying here
is we're gonna open up a port 80 on the
Gateway we're gonna do it for all hosts
again this is just a demo example I
wouldn't do this in real world when do
this in production all we're telling it
here is we're gonna set up a gateway
connecting to the FCO ingress gateway
that comes with this do by default which
is just another Envoy proxy and we're
gonna tell it to open up port 80 and
then we can actually create a virtual
service that tells requests when they
get to the ingress gateway were to
direct them to so remember we had those
named subsets of single and multiple a
couple of slides back so here we can
call it out specifically we attach this
virtual service to that so that gateway
we just created we match on a very
particular endpoint in this case slash
API slash weather and then we tell it to
just traffic split those two across the
single version and the multiple version
at a 90/10 split so that's it we're done
any traffic coming in through that
ingress gateway is now going to go
across those two subsets so that's good
we've solved kind of the we solved some
of the basic traffic splitting problem
but we haven't actually connected the
weather front end component to it yet so
the last step in that process is to
update the deployment excuse me all
we're changing here is we're changing
the backend location so this is actually
in the weather front-end deployment spec
for my piece for the components of
running kubernetes all I did is change
the host name of where it's supposed to
send traffic to now it's going to send
it through the sto ingress gateway
instead so really the only service that
had to change here that had to be
redeployed if you will was the weather
front-end component once you push this
out all the traffic when I'll start to
go through that other that other piece
the ingress gateway and then it'll get
split there so we did this without
deploying
any envoy proxies across those pods that
were there again the nice way to do this
is or the next thing about this is that
you're not having to redeploy or update
infrastructure and not having to inject
a sidecar quite yet and it's a good way
to sort of test and get familiarity with
the components with the api's that are
available to you but that's one example
of just kind of rolling it out what
about security how do you roll out
security in a measured and controlled
manner so in this case we are gonna have
to have injection turn on because really
at the end of the day for you to make
use of any security infrastructure
you've got to have the sidecar proxy
included in those pods to enforce those
policies so here what we did is we've
got two namespaces in our cluster one I
called legacy which is some vanilla
service and one called secure and in the
secure namespace I have sto and Auto
injection turned on so that means when I
deployed weather front and weather
back-end they got the Envoy proxy in
those pods so now what we want to do is
we want to slowly roll out M TLS we want
to roll it out so we secure the
infrastructure in the secure namespace
and we want to allow traffic from the
legacy namespace so the first thing we
do after we get these services up and
running is start with a security policy
and for those of you that are paying
really close attention
I had to shorten the names of the API
versions to fit on the slide so when you
if you have happened to look at these
later on don't copy from here copy from
the github repo that actually has the
correct yamo specified there but here
what we did is we are setting an empty
lat we're setting up the back-end
service we're turning on a policy there
for security we're saying we wanted to
have a permissive policy so that anybody
can connect to it from within that
cluster so the net effect is that this
service now has access to connect here
right so now it has a permissive policy
you can connect and weather front end
was not impacted by this it was because
it's got the Envoy proxy already it can
already connect to it and now what we
can do is apply a destination rule
that's saying anybody that's got the
proxy as part of their pod can use
mutual authentication so what this is
doing is
getting slowly rolling out em TLS to all
the services that can take advantage of
it
so this destination rule all it says is
use the sto mutual mode that means if
you are capable of doing M TLS let's go
ahead and do it so the net effect there
is that now we've got mutual TLS
happening between front and the back end
but still maintaining permissive access
to weather backend by the way and that
rule was was kind of under specified
right I left it a little bit open about
who could connect to it you can actually
get way more fine-grained and say only
certain services can utilize that
permissive mode so you have that ability
to control at a very fine-grained level
about who can access that thing without
using mutual authentication but now what
were to happen if we turn on strict
right if we if we take it from a
permissive mode or mutual mode to strict
right once we implement this policy and
update that policy from saying
permissive district that means anybody
that doesn't have the proxy that can't
do em TLS won't be able to connect to
this because what they're missing are
their certificates from things like
Citadel and the configuration from
galley to make it work so this is an
easy way to start with right again
remember the cluster we deployed was set
to permissive mode so that was already
kind of an open set up but we with
mutual we're actually able to turn on MT
less again on that service by service
basis anybody that could do it
would use it and then once we transition
to strict we cut off access to legacy
clients so this is a good way to think
about again it's a demo and I couldn't
fit that much information on our slide
but think about how you might again
slowly roll this kind of thing out
across a larger environment right if you
map this kind of problem to five five
hundred a thousand services it's an easy
way to enforce policy and enforce
security very quickly and it start
encrypting traffic between services
immediately so that was an incremental
rollout of security what about telemetry
right this is another I think key
feature of SEO where again you get that
monitoring and the tracing and logging
for free
and I mentioned this little bit earlier
but I love hitting it as much as I can
without additional instrumentation you
get this output directed to your choice
of back-end so what are the some of the
metrics that you get by default that you
get for free so you get things like
request count request duration
particularly for HTTP you get things
like size of request body the response
body size and then for TCP services you
get additional information like bytes
sent bytes received and this is actually
first source and destination as well so
you get variations for both so you can
actually track again
traffic inbound to your pod traffic
outbound and control and understand the
telemetry and what's happening there so
these metrics just start getting
published and again an open sources do
they go straight to Prometheus in the
version that you can install directly
through ggk console they go straight to
stack driver that's it
so at this point what I'd like to do is
switch to the demo can everybody read
that okay or is that big enough all
right no one said no so let's see I'm
gonna make sure we're on the right
cluster here so I'm in my hybrid 102
cluster and we can show you what's
running on here so I've got that example
app I talked about before the weather
front-end with weather back-end single
weather back-end multiple and I got a
little low generator script that's
generating and pushing traffic through
and so what I wanted to show you first
is the stack driver trace component so
this is again I didn't change anything
in my code I didn't instrument I didn't
add anything to it all I did is turned
on sto deployed these deployed those
containers with the sidecar proxy auto
injected and then it started sending
data distractor every trace immediately
and so I just did this earlier today so
that doesn't have an automatic report
there but we can actually dig in a
little bit further so this is the stack
driver Tracey why it'll by default give
you things like insights over the last
seven days or it'll create some auto
analysis reports for you or you can
actually just dig into individual URLs
or requests yourself so if I go over
here to the trace list
I can actually look and see I can look
at the latency of the requests that are
coming in again everything's being
generated by that load generator script
right now but actually dragged along
here and figure out so let's pick this
little section there I had a couple of
high requests so I can look here and say
I've got a request that was 301
milliseconds if I dig into that one
completely one I get this time line so I
can see again the request and how long
it took and then over here on the right
I get a lot more detail about things
like the time stamp and then I get to
see things like where it came from and I
think that's where it's really important
I can actually go here and say the
source workload was whether front end
right the URL was API whether this agent
that's using the track is the agent
that's built into the sidecar proxy or
built into mixer I should say and where
that traffic was going so we get some
level of detail here I can also filter
and go back and let's say I want to just
look at the external API calls I'm
making to the weather map API it's like
I say sent that API and filter request
there and now here I can see that most
of my requests are staying in this under
50 milliseconds boundary but we've got a
couple that have taken a little bit
longer and we can see again the timeline
it took for that request to go out and
the workload that that came from right
so in this case it came from the weather
back-end multiple service and here's the
actual URL it was requesting and I
didn't add any tracing here so I haven't
done anything to my code to enable this
now as you can probably imagine this
isn't telling me a whole heck of a lot
of information right because envoy can
track those requests from one proxy to
another it's capable of showing you this
data if you want to get that next level
of information if you want to know well
once it enters that request once that
request hits one of our methods in my
you know and my code I want to know
which line or which section of that code
is taking a long time if you want that
level of detail you'll have to actually
go in an instrument and you have your
choice of different instrumentation
libraries like either Zipkin or open
census attending on which one makes the
most sense for you but once you have
that level of instrumentation what you
would actually see here is a much more
granular kind of bar graph of the
different sections of your code and how
long they took so you get a much better
and clearer idea of what's actually
happening across there the nice thing
about that is you don't only have to add
the tracing statements into your code
you don't actually have to worry about
where to send it because again the proxy
is capturing that tracing reporting data
on its way out and it's actually
forwarding it on to mixer and mixer is
actually posting it to the back end so
that's a quick run through of the
tracing components here inside of
stackdriver trace let me quickly show
you all what it looks like if you were
to look at the open source Prometheus
Angra fauna so let me just quickly
forward the port over from Prometheus
and I'm doing this from a different
cluster that's running in another
project
all right so that's forwarding across we
can open a Prometheus now and inside
Prometheus you know you get the viewer
seen those sort of default Prometheus
piece here you can actually start
filtering by sto metrics so you can look
at sort of sto total requests and whoops
which is not very exciting all right
looking through all this it's a lot of
information a lot of data it's not
really sort of eminently visible by
default here even if you kind of graph
it out what's nicer is when you dig into
it using graph on ax so the Prometheus
and graph fauna that come with OSS sto
are pre-configured to be tightly coupled
and work together so Griffin is already
pulling data right off that Prometheus
instance so if I do the same thing here
but change that port forwarding to graph
fauna actually see a lot of interesting
metrics Ingrid fauna as well the other
nice thing about the instance of graph
fauna that we packaged in for you is
that it comes with some canned sto
specific dashboards so once you load the
griffin on main dashboard you go over to
the kind of the manage section which is
what i did and there should be an sto
folder there you can open that sto
folder and now we can actually start to
say well i want to dig into the service
dashboard in particular inside the
service dashboard right it opens with
any of the services that I'm calling so
because I have a service entry inside of
ISTE o for AP odds-on open weather maps
org it creates a service entry for that
here so I can browse by that so I can
actually see the client request volume
the success rate this one's not that
interesting but if we look at the
weather backend that gets a little bit
more interesting right we could see the
request volume the success rate and if
we continue on down incoming requests
and response code right the success rate
or the duration for some of these calls
again highlighting our ability to kind
of dig into these calls that might be
taking quite a long time right this
one's showing us that at the 99th
percentile it's returning about 950
milliseconds which is quite a bit and
there's some TCP specific ones here that
aren't filled in as well
same thing is true again of the weather
front end you can see those dashboards
and look at that traffic information or
you can switch to the the let's see
where is the sto workload dashboard
right another way to kind of look at the
information here so we'll switch to the
default namespace and we'll look at
weather backend multiple let's pick on
just one of those services so again we
can see how long things are taking the
duration by source response size etc and
we can see all the outbound and outgoing
requests as well so this is built in
right all those metrics I mentioned
earlier those things automatically
captured by Envoy Envoy it collects that
telemetry and then sends it off to mixer
mixer forwards it on from you and if you
remember the Sto at a glance image right
there's a lot of control plan components
and they function very much the same as
the kubernetes control plane does if one
of those pieces goes down for some
unspecified amount of time you're not
locked out of the traffic routing right
you might not be able to push any new
rules or new policies while maybe pilot
is down but the rules that were already
pushed out and in place those are still
being honored by Envoy sorry just like
if you lose the kubernetes api master
for a certain amount of time your pods
and your containers are okay you just
can't schedule anything new so you've
got a little bit of a window of time
before things really turn ugly to fix
things up and particularly in the case
of telemetry if mixer goes down or if
you lose access to that mixer component
envoy will actually read try to send
telemetry so you won't have these
dropouts over time of metrics missing
because mixer wasn't available for some
bit there so can we switch back to the
slides
perfect
all right so where do you go from here
right we have a couple of examples or a
few examples of how you can roll is to
go out in a slow measured manner across
an existing infrastructure or existing
cluster and I would say the two features
that stand out among you know what we
hear from customers and users in the
ecosystem are telemetry and security
right folks really love the ability to
sort of deploy a CEO and then get this
telemetry information very quickly right
cuz it's all quite a bit to be able to
use right off the bat and they also love
the security aspect right those two
features alone I think are enough to
make it worth it so what I would
challenge you to do is think about if it
still makes sense for you in a
production workload figure out which of
those things make sense do you want it
for traffic telemetry security and then
spend enough time where you feel
comfortable with those api's before you
start rolling it out and do it again in
that incremental fashion right you can
actually roll things out and say well
we're gonna deploy it not to the default
namespace we'll do it to a separate
namespace and we'll try things out there
before we roll it out to default or to
other ones where you might have
production workloads some light reading
to get you started
Meghan actually who is the previous
speaker in this room gave it both of us
worked together on series of blog posts
called the service mesh era and they're
good conceptual overviews but they've
actually got practical tutorials built
into each one of those and they go
through a lot more depth here around
traffic splitting Canaria rollouts
telemetry stuff that's our security one
as well and actually the last one in the
series focuses on some more advanced
topics in sto like mesh expansion adding
in VMs right we have a lot of workloads
that still exist on VMs I know I went
very kubernetes centric here but we want
to make VMs just as easy as we want to
make it with container so you can deploy
and expand your mesh now with VMs but
it's still a little bit more work it's
not as easy as just injecting the
sidecar but she's got a great example
there and then there's also examples of
running SEO in a multi cluster
deployment whether you have a single
control plane in one cluster or you have
multiple control planes so you can have
either one or both those setups so
that's a great series I would definitely
advise you to take a look at that and
then the traffic portion of this came
from a blog post that I wrote a few
months ago called
no incremental sto with traffic
management so that's another good
example it goes into little more depth
of how you could roll it out and there's
also a great docks on MTA less migration
and some of the conceptual things the
last two links are links to my personal
github where I have that weather info
app if you want to just have a quick
little example again I like that one
because it requires you to make that
service entry for outbound API access
and it's got a couple other nice little
components in there to try out and then
all the stuff I went through all that ya
know that I truncate in a couple of
slides is actually in this repo next
nineteen incremental SEO so it's all
there if you want to run through this
end-to-end and rollout traffic's totally
or roll out some of the security stuff
slowly there's a fully baked example
there before I close out I do want to
mention a few other talks that are
happening tomorrow these little bit more
200-300 level but I mean they're really
good tomorrow morning actually Megan and
I are gonna give a talk on how to debug
your deployments inside of sto right so
this is an example of you deployed us do
you deployed your services with the
sidecar proxy and something broke all
right and we're gonna take you through
three or four examples of things like
how do I debug traffic deployments or
traffic errors how do I D bug telemetry
right what if you have custom metrics
how do you get those to show up inside
that Prometheus that you've got as part
of open source sto and the last one is a
security one we're gonna go through I
think some work with M TLS and Jah
tokens as well so that's a very much a
demo centric specific exercise for
debugging or troubleshooting I should
say but then we've got a few other ones
as well but really I mentioned the
adding sto for VMs and expanding the
service mesh so that's tomorrow as well
second to last but not least we would
love your feedback about how to make a
better service mesh product right you
guys have we love the input from people
who are using SEO who are played with
this do who are interested in using SEO
why what drives that right we want to
help improve as much as we can so this
is feedback that we use to make it the
commercial version better as well as the
open-source version so by all means sign
up
fill out this form we'd love your
feedback in your help and then finally
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]